à l'heure où l'on découpe les arbres la
tronçonneuse à essence on les charge la
grue électrique voulons des souches les
vieux troncs à coup de bulldozer
on peut se demander
fauré recèle encore ce mystère ce
merveilleux c'est irrationnel si
attrayant peut-être chez certains hommes
quand on affronte en émission sur les
ardennes tout le monde nous a dit il
faut absolument voir à gap et
vous en doutiez pourquoi parce que c'est
ça a été beaucoup interrogé mission vous
interroge beaucoup s'il ya une raison
parce qu'on aime bien savoir certaine
curiosité voyous est ce que vous
connaissez les curiosités ou alors mais
oui en fait
certainement pourquoi
parlez nous un peu débat de la forêt
[Applaudissements]
j'aime technique faudrait beaucoup
d'heures pour vous faire quelque chose
de venir comprenez vous
en quelques minutes on rit on dit on va
essayer de vous résumer quelque chose
au royaume uni comme appareil moi j'ai
toujours travaillé dans vous comprenez
j'ai eu l'occasion de voir l'ancien
système
d'exploitation forestière du différend a
égalisé
il ya une différence colossale oui
forcément le la production est doublé
triplé 4 clés
[Applaudissements]
moi j'ai connu le débardage avec les
chevaux ne pas relâcher pour mobiles
elle est belle les chevaux s'étaient
fait quelque chose
quelque chose vous faire aujourd'hui
vous avez peut-être plus facile de
trouver un homme conduit un camion vous
auriez un peu conduire six chevaux
[Applaudissements]
maintenant qu'est-ce que vous faites
mais travaux mécaniques
tracteur ce surcoût réparation entretien
le graissage
et on voudra y est pas qu'est ce que
vous faites
tous les jours tous les jours ça venant
de travail tous les jours non pas de
journée oui mais j'ai bien aimé mon
travail est plus apte à dimanche quoi
d'image vous faites quoi
par devoir par
tradition si ça t'intéresse pas parce
que j'aime simple vous avez une notion
vous avez un sens du devoir ah oui
toujours qu'est ce que c'est le devoir
le devoir de chrétien soit derrière
leurs instruments
ils devoir de l'homme
ça serait de le faire aux compagnies
[Musique]